und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend mit größe kommt macht mit macht
kommt verantwortung deutschland könnte
sich aus seiner verantwortung fürs
weltklima vielleicht noch rausfinden
produziert ja nicht mal zwei prozent am
globalen co2 ausstoß aber europa hat
schon acht prozent auf europa kommt es
an die eu-kommission die behörde die
noch am ehesten so was wie eine
europäische regierung ist will etwas tun
seit heute liegt ihr vorschlag auf dem
tisch
europa soll bis 2050 co2 neutral werden
als erster kontinent das wird in vielen
eu-ländern manches auf den kopf stellen
und brauchte am ende die zustimmung von
27 regierungen mit sehr verschiedenen
vorstellungen von wirklichkeiten und
notwendigkeit an der gellinek über den
auftakt eines jahrhundert projektes
mindest gestern nacht taucht die
eu-kommission sich selbst ganz in grünes
licht die zeitenwende kommt soll das
heißen
dabei wird hinter den glasfassaden noch
immer gestritten um grenzwerte
reduktionsziele ausgleichszahlungen bis
heute mittag da lässt die präsidentin
gleich sechs kommissare und
kommissarinnen aufmarschieren die
botschaft alle stehen hinter dem paket
das europa und ein bisschen auch die
welt verändern soll
nichts von dem was wir heute vorschlagen
wird einfach sein es wird sogar verdammt
hast ich weiß das aber es ist etwas das
wir tun müssen es ist unsere pflicht
strategie nummer eins elektro fest um
den co2 ausstoß im straßenverkehr bis
2030 um 55 prozent zu senken setzt die
eu kommission auf elektroautos das laden
soll wie tanken werden alle 60 kilometer
eine soll der letzte neuwagen mit
verbrenner motor darf 20 35 verkauft
werden danach vor schluss sein
sehr kritisch sehen wir das faktische
verbot des verbrennungsmotors hier wird
der pfad der technologieoffenheit
verlassen und das halten wir für falsch
strategie nummer zwei co2 ausstoß kostet
für gebäude und straßenverkehr wird ein
eigener emissionshandel eingeführt
kraftstoff händler werden zertifikate
kaufen müssen heizöl benzin und diesel
dadurch für alle verbraucher in europa
teurer
frankreich hat bis zuletzt widerstand
geleistet so gut erinnert sich die
regierung an die gelb westen proteste
die auch mit einer benzinpreiserhöhung
begannen klimaschutz als sozialer
spaltpilz wir haben ganz
unterschiedliche einkommens strukturen
und lebenshaltungskosten und es würde
bedeuten dass der gut betuchte deutsche
suv fahrer der bulgarischen roma die
zertifikate für ihre ihrer heizstoffe
verkauft ein neuer klima- sozialfonds
soll ärmeren menschen helfen die
steigenden energiekosten zu bezahlen
strategie nummer drei der klima zoll
auch der rest der welt soll mitmachen
wer klimaschädlich hergestellte produkte
wie stahl oder zement in die eu
einführen will muss an der grenze eine
co2 abgabe zahlen eine art klima zoll
so soll die heimische industrie
geschützt werden die sauberer und teurer
produziert die wirtschaft selbst
fürchtet die abgabe ein co2 grenze
ausgleich bringt wird eine menge von
umsetzungsproblem mit sich bringen die
europäische kommission muss die frage
beantworten wie macht man es kompatibel
mit den regeln der
welthandelsorganisation dies ist nicht
beantwortet
zwei jahre lang hat die eu kommission
über das grüne paket das europa
verändern soll nachgedacht ab jetzt wird
sie für seine durchsetzung kämpfen
der klima kommissar und vizepräsident
der eu kommission ist der niederländer
und ehemalige außenminister franz
timmermanns guten abend nach größe guten
abend
timmermanns das wird ja ein riesending
und nun gibt es auf der welt drei
schwergewichte china usa europa was
produktion angeht sind die ungefähr
gleich groß china stößt da vor ungefähr
30 prozent des co2 der welt aus die usa
13 prozent 8 warum müssen dann
ausgerechnet die verbraucher europas
vorangehen und als erster das meiste
dafür zahlen weil ich glaube dass wenn
die uns unsere gesellschaft unsere
wirtschaft umgestalten wir auch als
erster die resultate davon bekommen also
die die wirtschaft weltweit wird
nachhaltig sein
das ist überhaupt keine frage und wer am
ersten
wem das am ersten gelingt wird auch als
erster davon profitieren und wir sehen
jetzt auch dass die amerikaner die
versuchen auch dasselbe zu machen was
wir gemacht haben die chinesen anderen
auch ihre politik ich glaube diese
weltweite entwicklung müssen wir führen
als europäer denn das ist für unsere
wirtschaft glaube ich wirklich die beste
lösung
die verbraucher kennen das schon dass
die politik in auch schwierige maßnahmen
immer als eine situation verkauft in
denen alle gewinner sind ganz besonders
auch die kleinen leute wie verträgt sich
das mit der erklärung jetzt gerade aus
unserem beitrag dass ein deutscher suv
fahrer einer bulgarischen bäuerin
sozusagen konkurrenz macht um co2
zertifikate ohne dass die frau das
überhaupt versteht wie das zusammenhängt
ach ich glaube wir müssen jetzt ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein das wir
eine karikatur der vorschläge machen
ich würde das gerne erklären ich das
auch gerne die mitgliedstaaten erklären
wir haben ja diese erfahrung schon in
deutschland mit diesem system und das
funktioniert ziemlich gut hat auch nicht
den preis sehr erhöht nur ein kleines
bisschen
und so hat aber so wird das auch ein
bisschen weh der preis muss er deutlich
jetzt nach oben gehen da sind sich alle
einig diese bescheidenen co2 preise
jedoch im moment in deutschland bezahlt
werden die sind ja nicht das was ihnen
der endeavour konzept finanziert in der
industrie haben wir schon ein co2 preis
von über 50 euro pro tonne
das war vor einem jahr noch 14 euro also
200 250 euro seien damit ihre rechnung
aufgeht
das stimmt aber nicht das brauchen wir
diese diese preise brauchen wir nicht
der preis wird höher werden aber wir
müssen auch unsere industrie und aus
unserer bürgerinnen und bürger die
möglichkeit geben sich daran anzupassen
das ist möglich das können wir schaffen
in den nächsten jahren dazu haben wir
jetzt auch als erstes kontinent haben
wir auch konkrete maßnahmen
vorgeschlagen das hat noch keiner
gemacht in der welt viele haben schon
gesagt wir wollen klimaneutral sein bis
20.50 aber kein kein land kein kontinent
hat noch ein konkretes einen konkreten
vorschlag gemacht das machen wir jetzt
und jetzt fängt die phase an woran wir
das mit mitgliedstaaten und europäisches
parlament besprechen was denen gefällt
schön das machen wir was die ihnen nicht
gefällt da müssten die mit anderen
vorschlägen kommen denn gesetzlich sind
wir verpflichtet unsere emissionen bis
20.30 mit mindestens 55 prozent zu
reduzieren bis 2050 auf null zu bringen
als in frankreich makro den benzinpreis
erhöhen wollte oder musste kamen die
gelb westen auf in deutschland weist die
politik besonders die der etablierten
parteien spd und cdu das im osten
deutschlands die klima themen der afg
die wähler zutreibt wie wollen sie das
den parteien die ja auch um ihre
machtverhältnisse besorgt sein müssen in
ganz europa nahe bringen dieses rezept
dann trotzdem durchzuziehen
dieses
diese ganze änderungen wird sozial
gerecht sein oder wird einfach nicht
stattfinden
und deshalb haben wir auch mit unseren
vorschlägen für eine ids systemen bei
gebäuden und bei transport haben wir
einen vorschlag gemacht dass es einen
sozialfond gibt damit die leute die sich
nicht selber leisten können diese
tradition zu machen eine unterstützung
bekommen bei ihren einkommen oder bei
der modernisierung der wohnungen oder
auch bei der bahn kaufen eines autos
damit wir die leute auch tatsächlich
unterstützen können damit wir dafür
sorgen dass keiner auf der strecke
bleibt bleibt dass alle mitmachen können
das ist unser anliegen das können wir
auch schaffen das können wir auch
beweisen und ich freue mich darauf dass
wir das jetzt mit den mitgliedstaaten
besprechen können wir haben später im
update des heute-journals ein gespräch
mit fried future fridays natürlich für
futures die haben errechnet dass ihre
maßnahmen die sie vorschlagen bei weitem
nicht ausreichen werden die seien jetzt
schon zu aufgeweicht haben sie da andere
fakten oder einfach mehr hoffen
ich bin mit der analyse nicht
einverstanden weil in dieser analyse
wird manchmal vergessen
wir sind verantwortlich für acht prozent
der emissionen weltweit
andere teile der welt wie sie auch
erklärt haben am anfang haben eine größe
verantwortlichkeit die ändern sich jetzt
auch die machen das nicht um uns einen
gefallen zu tun
die sehen alle dass wir in einer tiefen
tiefen klimakrise stecken und sie wollen
auch ihre politiken ändern
also wenn die welt schritt für schritt
in derselben richtung geht dann schaffen
wir das noch dann schaffen wir dieses
pariser abkommen noch es wird knapp das
gestehe ich gerne zu es wird knapp aber
wir können das doch immer schaffen
danke für das gespräch herr timmermanns
und einen schönen abend einen schönen
wünsche ich ihnen auch wenn es nicht
schon genügend verschwörungs mythen gäbe
dann hätte ich jetzt eine vorzuschlagen
irgendwie hat sich die eu kommission mit
dem wetter machern verabredet und für
deutschland eine lager zusammen gekocht
die von süden des nordosten eine extreme
lage und dramatische bilder produziert
tatsächlich ist es so dass es
tiefdruckgebiete wie das tief bernd die
sich für lange zeit über eine region
festhalten und austoben schon immer gab
dass sie häufiger werden liegt daran
dass die arktis und die luft darüber
immer wärmer werden und dem jetstream
dem antritt des wettergeschehens die
kraft entziehen
also liegt es am klimawandel die folgen
sind spürbar nicht irgendwann irgendwo
sondern jetzt und hier im märkischen
kreis im sauerland nimmt sich das wasser
seinen weg bericht sogar durch einen
damm ein feuerwehrmann ist ertrunken
während er im einsatz war und dutzende
anwohner müssen ihre häuser verlassen
vorerst kann keiner mehr in die wohnung
zurück wir gucken dass wir halt mal wenn
die medikamente gebraucht werden dass es
das ermöglichen
im nur 20 kilometer entfernten hagen
appellieren die behörden an die bewohner
zu hause zu bleiben
in einigen ortsteilen bleibt ihnen auch
nichts anderes übrig wo das wasser den
asphalt nicht aufgerissen hat steht es
bis zu anderthalb meter hoch auf den
straßen
die stadt hagen hat hilfe von der
bundeswehr angefordert in nordrhein
westfalen aber auch in rheinland-pfalz
steigen die flüsse weiter an und treten
über ihre ufer in der eifel arbeiten
anwohner und feuerwehr fieberhaft daran
sich vor den wassermassen zu schützen
ingolstadt in sachsen sind die fluten
ungebremst durch den ort gedonnert
als ein mann versucht sein grundstück
abzusichern wird er von den wassermassen
mitgerissen
er gilt noch immer als vermisst bei
tageslicht wird im bayerischen hof das
ganze ausmaß der schäden sichtbar
nachdem dort über 80 liter regen pro
quadratmeter runter kam zeitweise
herrschte sogar katastrophenalarm
hunderte notrufe gingen bei den behörden
ein die anwohner stehen noch unter
schock
deshalb habe ich selber noch nie erlebt
so kam das abwasser aus den toiletten
geschossen und das war besonders
interessant und lecker also das war
unglaublich und jetzt putzen war zum
glück habe freunde die uns helfen so
kämpfen mensch und natur mit den folgen
des unwetters während steve bernd weiter
über deutschland kreist
nachrichten nun von gundula gause
bundespräsident steinmeier hat
angesichts sinkender impfzahlen
eindringlich dazu aufgerufen sich gegen
korona impfen zu lassen
die ganze gesellschaft brauche den
impfschutz damit neue virusvarianten
nicht zu weiteren einschränkungen
zwingen
zugleich steigen die infektionszahlen
das robert koch institut registrierte
1548 neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
tages 563 mehr als vor einer woche
28 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incident stieg auf 7,1 die
deutlichste zunahme wird bei den 20 bis
24 jährigen verzeichnet auch in den
niederlanden ist die zahl der korona
neue infektionen stark angestiegen
dort liegt die sieben tage ins events
bei über 300 als grund nannten die
gesundheitsbehörden vor allem
ansteckungen eben bei jüngeren menschen
zuletzt hatten sich bei einem
musikfestival etwa 1000 besucher mit dem
virus infiziert ende juni waren in den
niederlanden fast alle corona maßnahmen
vorübergehend aufgehoben und auch
großveranstaltungen wieder erlaubt
worden
der konflikt zwischen polen und der eu
um die reform des polnischen
justizsystems spitzt sich weiter zu
das verfassungsgericht in warschau
urteilte heute einstweilige verfügungen
des europäischen gerichtshofes für das
polnische gerichtssystem seien mit
polens verfassung nicht vereinbar
der bgh will morgen endgültig
entscheiden ob eine bestimmte kammer des
obersten gerichts in polen die arbeit
aussetzen muss da sie so der vorwurf
nicht politisch unabhängig sei die
deutschen sicherheitsbehörden stellen
sich im vorfeld der bundestagswahl auf
zunehmendes cyberangriffe ein mögliche
bedrohungen seien unter anderem
beschimpfungen im netz sowie verbreitung
von falschen nachrichten das ziel von
hackern aus dem in und ausland könnte
etwa die kommunikation von parteien und
kandidaten werden so bundesinnenminister
seehofer
man tue aber alles um einen fairen
wahlkampf zu gewährleisten
die vorbereitung und durchführung der
wahl seien sicher im bayerischen kloster
seeon hat die zweitägige klausurtagung
der csu begonnen
im vorfeld bekräftigte csu-chef söder
dabei erneut die forderung nach
steuerentlastungen nach der
bundestagswahl
dies stehe schwarz auf weiß im
gemeinsamen wahlprogramm der union so
söder der damit cdu kanzlerkandidat
laschet widerspricht der wird morgen in
seeon erwartet und hatte zuletzt keinen
spielraum für steuererleichterungen
gesehen
also da gibt es auch keine
unterschiedliche interpretation werden
immer klar gesagt haben wahlprogramm da
haben uns ja wirklich bemüht um ein
gemeinsames wahlprogramm
da kann in einem koalitionspartner nicht
alles umgesetzt werden wenn es aber nur
nach uns ginge müsste das ja alles
umgesetzt werden der job war als
präsident jederzeit für eine
überraschung gut er hat leute in den
himmel gelobt und kurz darauf in die
hölle gewünscht seine außenpolitik
wechselte immer wieder die richtung
verbündete wurden über nacht zu gegnern
oder feinden und in einem war er immer
konsequent vor der wahl im amt nach der
wahl hat er alles getan
das vertrauen in die säulen einer
demokratischen gesellschaft zu
untergraben
gegen us behörden gegen unabhängige
justiz gegen kritische medien gegen das
parlament und am ende sogar gegen das
vertrauen in freie wahlen und ihr
ergebnis
diesen kampf führen seine treuen
republikaner bis heute weiter mit
andauernden angriffen gegen das ergebnis
von 2020 und änderungen des wahlrechts
für 2024 in washington und in den
bundesstaaten geradezu mit wildwest
methoden jetzt in texas benjamin daniel
bericht auf ihrem instagram account
postete die texanische abgeordnete john
terry dieses video ein polizist kommt in
ihr büro um sie mitzunehmen trifft aber
nur ihre mitarbeiter an
die abgeordnete saß zu diesem zeitpunkt
schon im flieger gen washington den
befehl zur festnahme hatte der sprecher
des hauses gegeben
ich fordere den sergeant at arms und
seine leute auf sicherzustellen dass
alle abgeordneten die unentschuldigt
fehlen hergebracht werden falls nötig
haben sie das recht sie festzunehmen
die geschichte beginnt mit
gesetzesvorhaben der texanischen
republikaner
sie fordern unter anderem eine
verschärfung des wahlrechts aus sicht
der demokraten würden dadurch vor allem
minderheiten benachteiligt also haben
sie einen hollywood reifen plan
geschmiedet und per telefonkette
organisiert das 51 abgeordnete heimlich
ausgeflogen werden dadurch fehlt dem
repräsentantenhaus nun das nötige quorum
um abstimmen zu können
seit der verabschiedung des wahlrechts
gesetzes mitte der 60er jahre haben wir
so einen rückschritt beim wahlrecht
nicht mehr gesehen dagegen müssen wir
etwas unternehmen
die demokraten können die abstimmung nur
verhindern wenn sie außerhalb des
bundesstaates bleiben ich als gouverneur
werde eine sondersitzung nach der
anderen einberufen monat für monat bis
eine abstimmung über die gesetze erfolgt
ist die republikaner weisen den vorwurf
zurück das abstimmen für minderheiten
erschweren zu wollen
es gehe vielmehr darum wahlbetrug zu
verhindern das nimmt ihnen der
us-präsident nicht ab das hat nichts mit
demokratie zu tun es geht darum dass
weniger menschen wählen können um
unterdrückung das verhindern einer
freien und fairen wahl ist das
unamerikanische undemokratische
unpatriotisch das man sich vorstellen
kann
und leider passiert es nicht zum ersten
mal der us präsident will sich für eine
bundesweite wahlrechtsreform einsetzen
die erfolgsaussichten sind gering da die
republikaner das vorhaben im senat
blockieren
joe biden fand auch deutliche worte in
richtung lehrer die noch immer glauben
die wahl 2020 sei ihnen gestohlen worden
trumps lüge sei eben genau das eine
große lüge
die texanischen demokraten wollen so
lange in washington bleiben bis die 30
tägige sonder sitzungsperiode in texas
beendet ist
ihnen allen ist jedoch klar solange es
keine bundesweite reform gibt können sie
mit ihrem boykott den prozess wo
lediglich aufschieben südafrika erlebt
derzeit den zerfall der staatlichen
ordnung aus demonstrationen werden
gewalttätige plünderungen bilder wirken
wie aus einem bürgerkrieg
auslöser der proteste sind unter anderem
blanke not gescheiterte wirtschaft
arbeitslosigkeit und hunger
dahinter stehen auch stammeskonflikte
ein abgewählter korrupter ex präsident
der im gefängnis sitzt weil er sich der
staatlichen untersuchungen stellen
wollte sandra theis berichtet aus
südafrika ein kleinkind wird aus einem
brennenden gebäude geworfen und gerettet
auch heute wurden einkaufszentren und
geschäfte leer geräumt zerstört in brand
gesteckt so wie hier in durban plünderer
schleppen davon was sie zu fassen
bekommen das alles angeblich aus protest
gegen die inhaftierung des früheren
präsidenten jacob zuma
natürlich geht es um jacob zuma sie
müssen beachten dass alles hat an dem
tag begonnen als summer verhaftet wurde
rückblick ende juni verurteilt das
verfassungsgericht summer zu 15 monaten
haft weil er trotz richterlicher
anordnung zuletzt nicht mehr vor einer
kommission erschienen war
die gegen ihn ermittelt es geht um
zahlreiche korruptionsvorwürfe super und
seine korrupte clique sollen den staat
hemmungslos geplündert haben
zuma selbst weist die vorwürfe von sich
inszeniert sich lieber als
freiheitskämpfer vor seinem haftantritt
vergleich der den heutigen rechtsstaat
mit dem apartheid-regime und sieht sich
erneut als opfer mich ins gefängnis zu
schicken
während des höhepunktes einer pandemie
ist in meinem alter dasselbe wie mich
zum tode zu verurteilen
genutzt hat es nichts vor ein paar tagen
erfolgt die verhaftung im polizeikonvoi
geht's ins gefängnis es ist der funke
der die gewaltsamen proteste auslöst
aufnahmen aus soweto gestern unmengen
von menschen plündern das giuliani
einkaufszentrum für die geschädigten ist
es eine katastrophe
ich habe hier mindestens vier menschen
beschäftigt was wird jetzt aus den
menschen die hier gearbeitet haben
das ist nicht fair wir wissen dass die
arbeitslosigkeit hoch ist aber wenn sie
so etwas tun wird die arbeitslosigkeit
noch größer mit politischem protest hat
das kaum noch zu tun
armut und arbeitslosigkeit sind durch
die kurve pandemie gestiegen und viele
nutzen das chaos aus mittlerweile wurde
das militär entsandt doch unter
kontrolle ist die lage noch nicht die
mögliche einführung eines digitalen euro
kommt einen schritt voran
die europäische zentralbank hat
beschlossen das projekt zwei jahre lang
konkret zu prüfen
der digitale euro sei so die ezb auf
jeden fall nur eine ergänzung zum
bargeld frank bethmann was hätte denn
der digitale euro was andere crypto
währungen die bitcoin nicht haben
ich sage es mal so man weiß wer dahinter
steht denn und ich denke dass der
wichtigste punkt im gegensatz zu starten
und unternehmen kann eine notenbank für
die ezb nicht pleite gehen und damit
wäre der digitale euro 100 prozentig
auswahl sicheres zahlungsmittel
ein weiteres wichtiges kriterium was
passiert eigentlich mit meinen daten
bislang organisieren beim elektronischen
bezahlen private konzerne die abwicklung
die meisten sitzen im ausland und
sammeln daten ein digitaler euro
hingegen wäre direkt bei der
europäischen zentralbank hinterlegt die
datenschutz-anforderungen werden
deutlich strikter und da man weiß wie
wichtig den menschen gerade dieser
aspekt der schutz von daten geworden ist
spricht natürlich auch das für einen
euro in digitaler form
und trotzdem gibt es widerstände gerade
in deutschland kennt man sehr an bargeld
ist das ein problem
ja zunächst einmal beteuert ja die ezb
dass es sich nicht darum gehen würde das
bargeld abzuschaffen
der digitale euro wäre nur eine
ergänzung gleichzeitig ist der digitale
euro zum erfolg verdammt denn digital
währungen sind auf dem vormarsch und
wenn europa das nicht mehr mit dabei ist
droht der euro möglicherweise an
bedeutung zu verlieren
wichtig wird es daher sein die europäer
mit zu nehmen sie zu überzeugen von den
vorteilen einer solch digitalen währung
frank bethmann vielen dank eine gute
nachricht und ein wichtiger schritt zur
bewahrung von einmaligem kultur erbe so
bewertet die unesco italiens ein
fahrverbot für große kreuzfahrtschiffe
in die lagune von venedig vor der
nächsten sitzung des
unesco-welterbekomitees in der zweiten
julihälfte bemühen sich von einer
drohenden herabstufung betroffene
regionen dar um das abzuwenden geben wie
venedig auch deswegen hat die
lagunenstadt beschlossen großen
kreuzfahrtschiffen das seit langem
heftig kritisierte direkte vorbeifahren
zu verbieten
es fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom
lotto am mittwoch sie lauten wie immer
ohne gewähr
112 15 26 33 49 superzahl 6 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7 am anfang liegt ja
meist etwas liebevolles in dem besuch
versucht das was man liebt zu ermessen
in dieser phase liegt ja auch immer ein
bisschen fortschritt in
luft bis das glück über gewonnene
zollstock millimeter vom skeptischen
blick auf eine waage abgelöst wird
zurzeit wird deutschland vermessen nicht
aus liebe aus technischer notwendigkeit
ein großes land das uns so stabil
vorkommt wieder boden unter den füßen
aber der ist ja nicht stabil
die form die größe die fläche die höhe
die tiefe von kontinenten verändert sich
etwa alle 13 jahre wird deswegen
nachgemessen im großen ganzen und auch
ganz genau
es kommt tatsächlich auf millimeter an
auch da berichtet elisabeth schmidt 13
jahre lang war er verborgen und gut
behütet das ist der heilige gral von
rinteln niedersachsen hauptheld der
neuvermessung deutschlands eine kleine
unscheinbare plakette
sie wird in dieser geschichte mit
spielen und in dieser aber von form
mitten auf dem niedersächsischen land
baut ein vermessungs trupp diese antenne
auf über der plakette die offiziell
geodätische grund netz punkt heißt 250
davon gibt es in deutschland die punkte
werden zurzeit neu vermessen in jedem
bundesland genaue position und höhe die
antenne empfängt dazu signale von
europäischen amerikanischen und
russischen satellitendiensten unsere
messdaten gehört und machte es deswegen
so genau wer diese dienste dahinter
haben die eben sicherstellen können dass
wir uns wirklich auch bis auf den
millimeter herunter in der genauigkeit
bewegen das was man da draußen im
straßenverkehr eben nicht hat da hat man
in der regel so einem meter bis fünf
meter genauigkeit die millimeter genauen
messdaten sollen künftig etwa autonomes
fahren verbessern damit fahrerlose autos
immer präziser die spur halten können
die neuvermessung soll aber auch einen
verdacht überprüfen deutschland bewegt
sich
genauer gesagt die erdplatte auf der
sich die bundesrepublik befindet dem
hauptkamm der bewegt sich tatsächlich
immer noch nach oben habe den kollegen
in bayern jetzt kürzlich auch mal gesagt
andreas die 3000 meter auf der zugspitze
geschafft er noch
am anderen ende deutschlands an der
nordseeküste müssen sie dagegen ihre
deiche wie hier in ostfriesland immer
höher bauen denn das land senkt sich ab
auch dadurch steigt der meeresspiegel
nicht nur durch den menschgemachten
klimawandel
wenn wir jetzt einen
meeresspiegelanstieg von 18 cm haben im
letzten jahrhundert dann kann man sagen
ungefähr zehn zentimeter sind ihm auf
die absenkung der langfassung
zurückführen und der rest auf den
menschlichen ein anteil group wie viele
zentimeter werden es in den nächsten
jahren seien sie hätten auswirkungen auf
den deichbau niedersachsen lässt gerade
seine sturmflut befestigungen für viele
millionen euro aufstocken
sie sollen dann für 100 jahre halten
sich herausstellen sollte dass dieses
land senkung sich zwei millimeter pro
jahr beträgt oder einstellt darauf dann
wird das für die nächsten 100 jahre sehr
20 cm irgendwann ausmachen und das
müssen wir dann natürlich in den
neuesten gutachten auch berücksichtigen
zwei jahre wird es dauern bis alle daten
der messkampagne ausgewertet sind
das heiligtum des deutschen
vermessungswesen hat inzwischen seine
aufgabe erfüllt genau 23 stunden 32
minuten und 25 sekunden sind wir wieder
hier in gewohnter und gleich nach dem
heute besonders wichtigen blick auf das
wetter empfehlen wir das auslandsjournal
[Musik]
guten abend das ist einfach zu viel
wasser für die kleinen bäche und flüsse
und wir fragen uns ja woher hat tief
bernd dieses ganze wasser dass die
verträge der irrt sich immer wieder
es schlaucht die warme und feuchte luft
aus richtung mittelmeer ein gleichzeitig
vermixt ist das dann mit der kühleren
und trockenen luft vom atlantik und
deswegen gibt es so enorme regenmengen
solche in köln hat es schon bis zum
nachmittag 80 liter regen pro
quadratmeter gegeben und bis samstag
erwarten wir im westen und im süden noch
mal 30 bis 120 liter regen pro
quadratmeter was weniger regen fällt
hier im osten oder auch im nordosten
aber insgesamt ist es doch wirklich sehr
früh schauen wir uns also die regen
vorhersage für die nacht an
sie sehen hier entlang des rheins aber
auch in baden württemberg wird es heftig
schütten und morgen regnet es dann vor
allen dingen in der südhälfte viel von
dem regen zieht aber auch aus
deutschland raus richtung niederlande
und richtung frankreich schauen uns die
nacht noch mal genauer an mit den
ergiebigen regenfällen im westen
dahinter lockern die wolken auch mal auf
und es bildet sich nebel oder dunst die
temperaturen sinken auf rügen auf 20
grad bis auf 16 grad geht es runter und
niederrhein am alpenrand sind es um die
9 grad
und morgen liegen die temperaturen in
einer kurve vom rhein main gebiet bis in
die lausitz bei 24 bis 29 grad kühler
ist es im süden und es gibt weitere
kräftige regenfälle und mit diesen
gewittern und regenfällen haben wir es
auch noch am freitag zu tun
zum wochenende beruhigt sich die lage
scheint nach